- Get higher!
- You can tell
he hasn't been going
because this is just pathetic.
- I don't know what to
expect from Crossfit at all.
I don't know much about it.
- I feel like everything
I know about Crossfit
is just things that I've heard from
other people or in the movies.
- I've taken one Crossfit class before
and it was a really hard work out.
Hard enough that I thought
I would never return.
- I imagine it's gonna be
someone towering over me,
telling me very loudly that
I'm not trying hard enough,
because I probably won't be.
- The energy of everyone
working out together
I'm sure helps but I'm not
a very competitive person
when it comes to this sort of thing.
- [Rocco] That kind of like
camaraderie really puts me off.
- At the end of the day,
my goal is to remain alive.
This might not be my cup of tea,
but we'll find out.
The first day was brutal, it
looked like a gym for Robocops.
- It's like really hot in there,
I've never sweat so much,
like, I've done hot yoga
and I feel like I've never
been that disgusting before.
- One of the interesting
things about Crossfit
is that everyday is a different work out,
which is why it's called
the work out of the day.
You know that it's gonna
be Olympic weightlifting
combined with high-intensity
interval training
and that you're gonna be dead.
- So, at minute one we're
gonna start with 15 Wall Balls.
If you finish your Wall Balls,
you have the rest of the minute to rest.
When the second minute turns,
you start your pull-ups.
You finish those up, have the
rest of the minute to rest.
We'll basically follow that
pattern for 20 minutes.
- We did a bunch of Wall Balls,
it was like cruel and unusual punishment.
- So a Wall Ball's this
thing where you just pick up
a big, heavy-ass ball, and
you throw it at a wall,
over and over, like Sisyphus.
If anyone ever says, "Hey,
you wanna do some Wall Balls?"
Just be like, "Nah, (beep) off."
- The delirium's setting in.
There you go, you got it.
(shouts of encouragement)
Drink lots of water, if
you get coconut water,
get some electrolytes in you.
- [Shane] You're my hero, Rocco.
You're my inspiration.
- I feel like I only sweat
like that in a sauna.
- It was about what I expected,
which is pretty rough.
- I just left, like,
"I don't know if I can
ever go back and do this again."
I wanna die.
And I had two more months of it.
So.
- I mean, I don't smell like myself,
I smell like many people's sweat combined.
- Waking up for class was probably
the hardest part about it.
In about 20 to 30 minutes, I'm gonna be
in a very hot room, yelling and sweating.
You know, you get real
tired of waking up early,
but afterward, look, I'm ready to work!
I could swallow the world whole right now!
- So, I'd go to Crossfit from 7 to 8,
and then I'd have from 8 to 9 to like
rush home, get ready, and come in to work.
And so, I always looked like
a bag of ass, coming in to work.
I hurt so bad.
- All right, well this
is our mid-way point.
- I don't feel that different,
I feel like the work
outs have gotten easier
and then more difficult
and then easier again.
It's just so varied that
it doesn't feel like
something you can ever prepare for.
- It's been a good
jumpstart to working out
and after this, I can't complain
about any workouts that I ever do.
- All right, well,
here's to another month.
Cheers.
- I don't know, like a month in,
I couldn't go on a Monday, and
so I made it up on Tuesday.
And Shane wasn't there.
- I saw Maycie's name
and time on the board,
because she was going to
class right before me,
but I never saw Shane's name.
I suspected that maybe he
was going on a different day.
- Sometimes, your
schedule's a little crazy.
- [Maycie] And then I went
Wednesday, Shane wasn't there.
- [Shane] Yeah, I started
really, really slipping.
- [Maycie] And I was
like, "When is he going?"
- I just straight-up
lied to Maycie's face.
- But she got more sleuthy than I did.
- Today I'm going to the Tuesday class.
I'm gonna ask the trainer,
Ethan, if he's been coming.
- For a while, I got away with it.
- Last time he's been in is
8/21 on Friday at seven a.m.
- What?
Oh my god, he's in so much trouble!
So we decided we needed to punish him.
- We're here to shame Shane.
That's the name of the work out today.
- So we had the two trainers
surprise him at his desk.
Hey Shane, we have some visitors for you.
- I saw the two Crossfit
instructors walk in,
that's not a thing you wanna see.
It was like waking up and
seeing a vampire in your room.
Yeah.
- We figured that it'd be fair
to kinda bring the work out to you.
- [Shane] Sure.
- So we're gonna do a
set amount of Burpees
and Wall Balls per day that we've missed.
- OK, all right.
I just gleefully accepted,
because here's the thing,
they thought it was a
punishment, but to me,
I was like, "Great, I've
skipped numerous classes."
I don't know if the little
cheerleader outfit was necessary.
- He's going to be doing eleven rounds
of ten Wall Balls and then ten Burpees.
- Shane, make your way to the wall.
I didn't mean lean against it!
- [Rocco] You know,
watching that punishment
was somewhat satisfying,
because it was in the
middle of the work day.
(laughing)
- Yeah, it was funny.
- It was one of the low points of my life,
but once again, entirely worth it.
That was a lot of fun.
I wish I did this every afternoon.
- You met the challenge head on,
however long it took
him, with good spirits,
and that's really what it's all about.
- For our last class, we
invited some of our coworkers,
two of whom are like
really big Crossfitters.
And then Ryan, just because,
you know, look at him.
- Let's go, let's do it.
- [Rocco] That was the
most brutal work out
that we had to do,
and I think that that
was a great end note,
because the three of us felt totally sick.
- [Maycie] It was mostly cool
to see Ryan struggle through it.
- He looked like he was gonna
throw up a couple times.
- I'm sweating vodka.
- To be fair, I also almost threw up.
- And then obviously Kate and Jordan
kicked all of our asses, because somehow,
they actually love Crossfit.
- I'm not cut out for Crossfit.
- [Shane] Yeah, you are.
- I think Crossfit is good for anyone
at any skill level, to
push themselves past
what they think their capabilities are.
- [Maycie] It was cool
to like challenge myself
and see that I was stronger
than I thought I was.
- I could see how it
appeals to a lot of people.
There's like a great group mentality.
- [Maycie] The instructors,
like Ethan and Mike,
were awesome and super supportive.
So I can definitely see how people form
their Crossfit gym into this community.
- Crossfit is fun too,
like I'm not a person
who's into team sports at all,
I don't really like high
fives or round of applause,
but there was something nice about
feeling accomplished and
having someone near you
confirm that you, that you
lived through that work out.
- [Mike] Yeah, Rocco!
- [Shane] You know, it
was nice dipping my toe
in the water for a little while.
It was a good dip.
- Never gonna do it again.